James with grant on his hip fires to a
cutting Caruso for the Lakers by four
timeout Denver they switch on James he's
got yoga John with a shot clock at five
and he loves the three in this situation
instead he drives gets past yo gets late
but the left hand is good LeBron James
with a 30 point night that is a bad
match for Denver
Yogesh underneath and Prague able to
adjust his body in midair and get the
layout talked about how elite the Lakers
are defensively on the half court
Harris driving hanging
[Applause]
jump shot but Harris here good
verticality played by caldwell-pope
here's the switch Craig's on James with
four with three James with two gets the
shot away and over time here we go cats
finds Murray on the backdoor
gets the lamp right down the middle of
the lane yo kids with the ball in the
middle floor is a problem James Wow one
shot with his back to the rim by the
time he released the ball missed the
shot but then Denver gives it right back
with a turnover Anthony Davis wide open
look and he wells Holman 335th game
reset 10 or more assists bodies and
Denver's going to keep possession the
shot clock at four good luck for Harris
drive and pick Anthony Davis three right
in front of the Denver